[Musique]
danse et on se faisant plaisir danser
pour montrer son savoir-faire et
représente dignement son école ici les
variations imposé
[Musique]
danse contemporaine indienne -o
classique modern jazz
pas moins de 150 candidats cette année
sur les planches de l'atrium pour le
concours régional
un peu plus d'une minute d'expression
contemporaine on voit les ce qui manque
on voit ce qui ce qui peut être un peu
plus amélioré au revoir et du coup ça
permet aux amis se dépasser donc c'est
ça leur fera prendre conscience aussi
que ce n'est rien n'est gagné
c'est bien parce qu'on a réussi en cours
que ça va réussir sur scène et donc
c'est très important pour des enfants de
cet âge là ils devront aussi mais
surtout pour l'un pour cet âge là ça
leur permet de s'affirmer
calais
dalé
d
on sort du lot déjà par le travail qui a
été fait en amour avec les professeurs
jusque là les nez quand même partenaire
de toutes les écoles de danse est une
fédération de la martinique et est du
coup donc beaucoup de travail
une grosse préparation mentale parce que
c'est quand même pas évident de se
retrouver tout seul sur scène
et puis surtout on essaye de briller
passe pas encore forcément par chantal
en mai par rapport à la manière dont on
se présente par rapport à la manière
dont on danse
[Musique]
la ds classique c'est pour dévaler mes
sentiments et aussi pour le plaisir et
ce concours ce concours c'est pour
m'amuser pour montrer ce que je sais
faire rougir
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'étais ravi de ma compagnie danton son
parcours et je les trouvais excellente
6e sur scène et j'ai apprécié germain et
c'est ce moment mais objectivement wii
est agréablement surprise ils ont entre
8 et 25 ans du solo au gros fille ou
garçon
il s'agit donc de décrocher une place
pour le concours national prévu du 29
mai au 1er juin à valenciennes
un concours qui réunit chaque année près
de 3400 danseurs et danseuses
[Musique]